Okay. Guten Tag. Mein Name ist Bulur. Ich bin die Distabene der Arztin auf der Station und würde gerne das erste Gespräch mit Ihnen führen. Ist das Ordnung für Sie?
Das ist in Ordnung für mich, ja, natürlich.
Okay, so als werde ich ein paar Fragen zu Ihrer Person stellen, dann direkt Ihren aktuellen Bescheiden übergehen. Wie heißen Sie denn?
Ich heiße Uro Schlüter.
Uro.
Udo Schlüter.
Könnten Sie Ihren Vorunternahmen bestabieren?
Der Vornamen ist U-D-U.
Und der Familienname ist S-C-A-Schlüter.
S-C-A-L-U-U-Mann, also U-T-E-R.
Ja, Schlüter.
Schlüter.
Wie will er denn machen, ne?
Okay, Herr Schlüter. Wie heißen Sie?
Ich bin 48 Jahre alt.
48, okay. Und wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Am 6.07.77.
6.07.77.
Könnten Sie wiederholen?
Am 6.07.77.
7.07.77.
Okay, ja, ich verstehe. Danke schön.
Und wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin 81.
80.
1,80 Meter, ne?
Ja. Und wie viel wiegen Sie?
Über so 86, 87 Kilo.
7,80. Okay.
Und wie heißt Ihr Hausarzt oder Ihre Hausarztin?
Das ist Dr. Freudenberg.
Dr. Freidenberg.
Okay.
Was führt Sie heute sonst? Wie kann ich Ihnen helfen?
Ja, so. Mir geht es eigentlich schon eine ganze Weile nicht so gut.
Ich habe immer so Bauchschmerzen.
Ich habe immer so ein Bauchschmerz.
Und irgendwie merke ich so,
dass ich in letzter Zeit wirklich schlapp bin.
Und dass ich auch so ein Abend gar nicht so richtig zur Ruhe komme.
Ich bin so kribbelig und unruhig.
Diese Bauchschmerzen, das wird schon irgendwie mehr.
Ich habe auch, also, ja.
Ich merke das auch,
dass ich gar nicht gut belasten kann,
wenn ich mich ein bisschen anstrengen.
Da bin ich ganz aus der Buste.
Und oft ist mir auch schlecht.
Ich zitter mit einmal auch so ein bisschen.
Das ist ganz merkwürdig.
Und, ja, also, irgendwie merke ich so,
mit mir ist im Augenblick nicht viel los.
Und mein Hausarzt, da bin ich zufrieden.
Aber der hat nur gesagt, ja, Sie müssen mit dem Alkohol aufhören.
Aber das ist leichter gesagt als getan.
Aber das habe ich gedacht. Ich gehe mal direkt hier zu Ihnen.
Okay.
Seit wann haben Sie Bauchschmerzen?
Das geht schon drei Monate, würde ich sagen.
drei Monate.
Und wo genau sind die Schmerzen?
Unterbauch oder Bauchschmerzen?
Genau, sind die Schmerzen.
Unterbauch oder?
Nee, mehr so im Oberen Bauch.
Oberhalb vom Bauchnabel, würde ich sagen.
Okay, Oberbauch und Nabelberein.
Nicht rechts oder linker Seite.
Ja, ich würde schon sagen, ja, überall da so.
Okay.
Und haben Sie jetzt Schmerzen?
Ja, ich habe ständig so ein bisschen Schmerzen.
Und mir ist ständig so ein bisschen schlecht.
Und ich bin eben auch so unruhig.
Und manchmal schaffe ich es nicht mal richtig,
mir meine Zigarette anzuzünden, weil dieses Feuerzeug so zittert.
Ich bin so unruhige Hände.
Und ja, es ist alles nicht gut zur Zeit.
Okay.
Wie stark sind Ihre Schmerzen auf einer Schmerzskala von 1 bis 10?
Ein sehr starker Schmerz entspricht.
Sehr starker Schmerzen.
Also sehr stark.
Es ist ja nicht so, wie wenn ich mir mit einem Hammer auf den Daumen haue.
So ist es nicht.
Aber es ist schon so, dass ich das ständig merke.
Vielleicht so in der Mitte, bei 5 vielleicht?
Vielleicht, okay.
Ja, ich verstehe.
Ich habe das gesagt.
Sie fühlen sich zittern, krebeln mit Finger?
Ja, meine Hände zittern so ein bisschen.
Ich habe so unruhige Hände,
dass ich manche Sachen gar nicht gezielt machen kann.
Dann fällt mir etwas aus der Hand.
Und dann muss ich mich bücken.
Und es ärgert mich.
Okay.
Ich traue die Schmerzen irgendwo hinaus?
Nein, die sind da im Bauch.
Ja, da sind die.
Okay.
Und denken Sie,
das ist eine bestimmte Auslösung
für diese Schmerzen oder Beschwerden?
Die sind eigentlich dauerhaft da, die Schmerzen.
Okay.
Und sind die Schmerzen dauerhaft?
Oder gehen Sie auch wieder weg?
Nein, ich sage ja gerade, die sind ständig da.
Also es gibt kein, nix, wo ich jetzt sage,
damit fängt es an.
Und ich würde auch sagen,
die sind immer da und gehen nicht wieder weg.
Okay, können Sie Ihre Schmerzen beschreiben?
Sind die Schmerzen krampfartig?
Oder dumpf oder stehend?
Nee, es drückt halt so. Es drückt immer so auf den Bauch.
Ja.
Okay, du kannst die Schmerzen.
Haben Sie Fieber auch?
Hab ich jetzt nicht gemessen, glaube ich, aber nicht.
Nee, fieber ich fühle ich mich nicht.
Okay, ist Ihnen ein Übel?
Übel ist mir ja, ja, ja.
Okay, haben Sie erbrochen?
Was passiert das schon mal?
Aber jetzt auch schon ein paar Tage her, einmal musste ich mich übergeben,
aber da habe ich vielleicht auch ein bisschen was Falsches gekriegt.
Okay, ja, okay.
Haben Sie nicht eine besondere Veränderung aufgefallen?
Ist Ihnen...
Ist mir keine besondere Veränderung aufgefallen?
Haben Sie eine Druckgefühl?
Oder ist Ihnen eine Schwellung im Bauch aufgefallen?
Ja, sagen Sie das genau.
Also meine ganzen Hosen sind mir kneifend, die sind mir zu eng.
Also mein Bauch ist irgendwie dicker geworden, ja.
Dicker geworden?
Okay, ja, ich verstehe.
Haben Sie...
Ist Ihnen aufgefallen, dass Ihre Fuß- oder Bein geschwollen ist?
Die Füße sind nicht geschwollen, würde ich nicht sagen,
aber genau habe ich da nicht geguckt.
Okay, okay, ich verstehe, sehr gut.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Wasserlassen oder Stuhlgack?
Beim Wasserlassen.
Eigentlich kann ich auf die Toilette gehen, ganz normal.
Was mir aufgefallen ist, ich habe in letzter Zeit ordentlich Blähungen, ja.
Okay, haben Sie auch Sotbrinnen oder Sauerauchstoße?
Ja, eigentlich nicht.
Diese eine Mal, als ich mich übergeben musste, ja, aber sonst eigentlich nicht.
Okay, okay, sehr gut.
Haben Sie in letzter Zeit ungewöhnlich ab- oder so genommen?
Ja, ich wieg mich ja jetzt nicht so oft, ich bin ja kein Model, ne.
Aber ich glaube schon, dass ich ein bisschen zugenommen habe, ja.
Irgendwann auch die Hosen druck- kneifen, weil ich so...
Ich bin schon ein bisschen dicker geworden, das stimmt.
Okay, haben Sie Nachtschweiß?
Nachtschwitzen, manchmal schwitzen Sie Nacht ein bisschen,
aber also ja, nicht so doll.
Okay, haben Sie in Ihrem Bauch oder anderen Körperteile
irgendwelche Veränderungen aufgefallen?
Hautveränderungen?
Ja, Hautveränderungen.
Gerblich oder einige...
Ist mir nicht aufgefallen, ne, aber...
Roter Flecken, ne, ist mir nicht aufgefallen.
Ja, okay.
Okay, ist bei Ihnen irgendwelche Grundschere Erkrankungen bekannt?
Also, ja, mein Arzt sagt, ich hab dumm...
Da bin ich halt mal gewesen, aber...
Ja, da hat mir der Arzt gesagt, dass meine Leberwerte ein bisschen schlecht sind.
Und ja, deswegen bin ich da jetzt auch nicht mehr hingegangen,
weil der mir gedacht hat, ich soll kein Alkohol mehr trinken,
aber machen wir das mal, ja.
Okay, wie viel trinken Sie, Herr Schulter?
Ja, also trink schon ein paar Bier am Tag, so fünf, sechs Flaschen
und vielleicht noch ein paar Schnäppse oder so, ja.
Sechs Flaschen Bier und Schnaps?
Ein bisschen Schnaps, ja, noch ein paar Kurze trinke ich schon auch noch, ja.
Okay, seit wann trinken Sie?
Ach, schon ewig lange.
Ja, bestimmt schon 20 Jahre, als junger habe ich auch schon viel getrunken
und ja, aber so, da habe ich mich so eingepennt,
weil setz ich das schon Bier, ein paar Schnaps zu am Tag, ja.
Okay, und im Alter von 20 Jahren trinken...
Oh, warte mal, ich muss mal eben ganz schnell die Zimachen.
Deswegen mit dir zugegelt.
Ja, Sie trinken im Alter von 20 Jahren.
Sie trinken im Alter von seit dem Alter von 20 Jahren.
Nee, nee, nee, ja, früher habe ich nicht ganz so viel getrunken,
aber so seit 20 Jahren trinkst du das Pension.
Okay, rachen Sie auch, Herr Schulter?
Ja, ein paar Päckchen am Tag brauche ich schon, ja.
Einpacken, einpacken, okay.
Seit wann rachen Sie?
Ja, auch schon so seit 20 Jahren, ja.
20 Jahre, okay.
Hatten Sie jemals Kontakt mit Drogen?
Das ist ein Rhythmus.
Drogen, ne, eine Drogen habe ich nichts zu tun, ne, ne, schnapp Sie ja,
aber keine Drogen.
Okay, treiben Sie regelmäßig Sport?
Nein, das ist wirklich nicht, nein, aber meine Arbeit ist auch anstrengend.
Wissen Sie, ich arbeite auf dem Bau und im Tiefbau und ja, da hat man eigentlich genug Bewegung.
Okay, Sie arbeiten als Tiefbau.
Im Tiefbau, ja, also als Bauarbeiter, ne?
Bauarbeiter, okay.
Und sind Sie verheiratet?
Ja, ich bin geschieden.
Geschieden, okay, das tut mir sehr leid.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, aber die leben bei meiner Frau, ne?
Und die sind jetzt auch schon relativ groß.
Sie haben eine Tochter?
Ne, zwei Kinder.
Okay, sind Sie vollständig geimpft?
Meine Kinder?
Nein, Sie.
Ich?
Ja, ich habe mal so eine Corona-Impfung, habe ich mal gemacht, ja, aber dann eigentlich nicht mehr.
Ich habe gedacht, das tut mir bestimmt nichts.
Ich bin ja immer draußen an der frischen Luft.
Okay.
Haben Sie irgendwelche Allergien oder Unverträglichkeit?
Ja, echt, an alles vertragen.
Also, ich bin gegen nichts allergisch.
Okay, sehr gut.
Haben Sie in Lesse seit im Ausland?
Ne, das kann ich mir nicht leisten.
Okay, ich möchte ein paar Fragen über Ihre Familiengeschichte.
Gibt es in Ihrer familiekronische Erkrankung?
Ja, also, die leben alle nicht mehr.
Das hat, ja, also, mein Vater lebt nicht mehr.
Meine Mutter, der geht so nicht so gut, die hat Diabetes, Alterszucker da, ne?
Die hat auch ein bisschen hohen Blutdruck.
Und mein Vater, der war völlig gemänt zum Schluss.
Und der hatte auch irgendwie eine Lebererkrankung, ja.
Okay.
Haben Sie Geschwister?
Ne, Geschwister habe ich nicht.
Okay, würden Sie schon einmal operiert?
Ja, ich hatte mal, ich hatte mal so ein Beinbruch.
Es war im Rahmen der Arbeit da, es mir das passiert.
Welcher Bein?
Im linken Bein.
Okay.
Und da war der Unterschenkel, war halt gebrochen und musste operiert werden.
Und das ist aber auch schon 15 Jahre her.
15 Jahre, okay.
Das war das Komplikationus?
Ja, so weit war das dann, also das war halt ein komplizierter Bruch,
aber die Operation als solche hat ja gut geklappt, ja.
Sie haben gesagt, Sie haben Lebewerte, aber ist bei Ihnen eine Genaldiagnose,
Genalerkrankung bekannt?
Ja, ich bin da nicht mehr so aufs hingegangen zu meinem Hausarzt.
Okay.
Nehmen Sie regelmäßig Medikamente ein?
Ja, wenn ich mal Kopfschmerzen habe, dann nehme ich mal so ein Aspirin oder so, was man so hat.
Welche Dosierung kennen Sie?
Oh Gott, versteht da drauf.
Kann das sein 500 oder so, ja.
Okay, 500, okay.
Wenn einer nicht hilft, nehme ich auch noch eine zweite, aber meistens hilft es schon.
Okay, haben Sie höchsten oder Atemnot?
Ja, also manchmal habe ich so ein bisschen trockenen Husten.
Da kommt nichts raus, aber das kommt halt auch vom Rauchen, denke ich.
Ja, ich glaube, Sie haben recht.
Aber haben Sie Atemnot besonders vor drei Monaten oder innerhalb drei Monaten?
Ich habe in den letzten drei Monaten also nicht mehr als sonst.
Ich muss halt mal Husten, ja.
Okay.
Ja, Herr Schulter.
Mörten Sie etwas Hübschen fürgehen?
Muss ich wissen sollte?
Ich möchte natürlich wissen, was man mal dagegen tun.
Da gibt es irgendwelche Tabletten, dass es mir wieder besser geht,
dass ich wieder besser auf die Beine komme und dass es mir nicht immer so schlecht ist
und dass ich wieder ein bisschen besser drauf bin.
Okay, Sie haben eine Schmerzmittel angenommen und dann hat er mich schon geholfen.
Ich habe richtig verstanden.
Nein, nein, nein, ich wollte, nein, die Schmerz-Tabletten,
die nehme ich ja immer nur, wenn ich Kopfschmerzen habe oder so.
Ja, okay.
Ja, aber jetzt gegen diese Bauchschmerzen, da helfen ja Kopfschmerz-Tabletten eigentlich nicht.
Aber dagegen würde ich gerne Tabletten bekommen,
dass sie mir irgendwas verschreiben, was mir gut tun,
dass ich wieder gesund werde.
Ja, okay.
Ja, ich werde alle notwendige Medikamente verschreiben,
bitte machen Sie es, keine Sorgen.
Aber haben Sie für diese Beschwerden früher beim Hausarzt besucht
und er hat eher Sie ein Medikament verschrieben?
Nein, nichts verschrieben, nein, nein.
Nein, okay.
Okay Herr Schulter, ich habe keine weiteren Fragen.
Haben Sie Fragen an mich?
Ja, wie gesagt, was man dagegen tun kann, dass es mir wieder besser geht.
Ja.
Okay.
Ich werde Beschwerden können, viele Ursachen haben.
Deshalb kann ich Ihnen leider noch keine Antwort geben,
aber sonst werde ich Köpferlinge untersuchen,
dann Blutabnehmen und eine Laboverte überprüfen.
Eine Laboverte überprüfen.
Und ich werde Beschwerden mit meinem Oberarzt besprechen.
Sobald die Ergebnisse vorliegen, kann ich Ihnen genaures sagen.
Okay.
Ja, okay, das klingt doch okay.
Okay, jetzt bitte gehen Sie in den Behandlungszimmer
und ich werde gleich so Ihnen kommen.
Ja, gut, okay.
Ich warte dann daneben an.
Herr Schulter, das war gut, nein.
Doch, war gut.
Ja, weiß ich, ob man mal Fragen hat.
Ich habe eine Frage.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Stuhlgang?
Ja, habe ich eben verneint, aber tatsächlich ja,
ein bisschen Durchfall habe ich schon manchmal.
Manchmal. Seit wann haben Sie Ushfa?
Ach schon lange, immer mal wieder.
Seit drei Monaten oder?
Ja, länger.
Wie sah Ihr Stuhl aus?
Ja, ja, also das, was, wie der sonst auch aus,
nur halt ein bisschen flüssiger, ja.
Flüssiger. Okay.
Wie ist Ihr Appetit?
Ja, Essen schmeckt nicht so gut, Trinken geht besser, ja.
Okay, danke schön.
Haben Sie Schlappprobleme beim...
Ja, ich bin nur ein bisschen ruhig zu teilen,
deswegen kann ich nicht gut schlafen.
Also ich bin so kribbelig, ja.
Leiden Sie unter volle Gefühl im Bauch?
Völlige Gefühl, ja, ich habe so Druck im Bauch, ja.
Ob das volle Gefühl ist, weiß ich nicht, ja.
Hat jemand noch Fragen?
Guten Tag, Frau Berastin.
Ich habe einen neuen Patienten vorgestellt.
Haben Sie Kurseit für mich?
Mhm. Okay.
Der Patient heißt Udu-Schlüta, ist 48 Jahre alt,
1,80 m groß und 2,80 kg schwer.
Nein.
Und Herr Schulte stellte sich heute bei uns
wegen seit 3 Monaten
Bestehender, Druckhänder, Düffüser,
Epigastrischerschmerzen ohne Ausstrahlung vor.
Der Patient berichtete, dass die Schmerzen langsam aufgetreten sind
und sich mit der Seite verschlechtert haben.
Die Schmerzintensität liegt bis 5 von 10 auf der Schmerzkala.
Und der Patient klagte überall,
neuseher und einmal,
Neuseherregende wie Flatulenz, Asites
und Trockenytosis.
Trockenytosis.
Die Fragen nach Hauptveränderung oder Beinödemä
und Dispina wurden verleitet.
Die vegetative Anamnese ist unauffällig bis auf Insomni und in Apathens.
Und der Patient hat auch berichtet über Sitter und Kribbeln mit Händen.
Mit der Hände.
Und er berichtete, dass sie manchmal Diöre lang gesagt hat,
hat die Anforderung bei der Patientin,
bei dem Patientin ist keine Bekannte.
Oder der Patient hat keine Bekannten für Erkrankungen
und er nimmt, gelegen by bedarf 500 mg,
es wird uns als Gehgengopch merken.
Bei der Patientin wurde für fünf Jahre aufgrund einer Femur Fraktua,
eine Ostdeö Senteze, 4.Fürth war 4.Fürth.
In der Familienanamnese wurden angegeben, dass sein Vater,
sein Vater Demans hat,
Demans und eine Lebererkrankungen hat.
Und seine Mutter hat Diabetes Melutus II und Arterelei Hpertoni.
Er ist ein Seilkind, er ist ein Bauarbeiter.
Und er ist geschieden, hat zwei gesunde Kinder,
er ist verständlich und hat keine Allergien oder Verträglichkeit.
Er war unabhängig, er trinkt seit zwei Jahren
Einpackung Zigaretten pro Tag.
Er trinkt keine Zigaretten.
Keine Zigaretten.
Er trinkt keine.
Er raucht seit 20 Jahren Einpackung Zigaretten pro Tag
und im Altafon seit 20 Jahren trinkt er 6 Flaschebier und Schnaps 7 Tag.
Er trinkt keine.
Der Patient hat für diese Beschwerden beim Hausarzt aufgesucht.
Er hat den Hausarzt aufgesucht, ja?
Aufgesucht, aber er hat ihm keine Medikamente verschieben
oder ohne Beschwerung.
Aber der Patient berichtet, er hat Hochwerte, Hochlebewerte.
Erhöhte Lebewerte?
Lebewerte.
Aber habe keine Diagnose, aber er hat keine Diagnose.
Und die Analyse...
Warum ist er jetzt nicht zum Hausarzt gegangen?
Warum? Für diese Beschwerden? Nein.
Der Patient habe seit 2 Monaten bei der Beschwerden.
Aber wenn er seine Hausarzt besucht, die Hausarzt immer gesagt hat,
Alkohol, Karrens, ja?
Und Nikotin, Alkohol und Karrens hat erfohlen.
Das ist erforderlich, ja?
Ja, genau. Das hat ihm nicht gepasst, ne?
Ja, der Patient muss Nikotin, Alkohol aufhören.
Die anonystische Angaben deuten am Ehesten auf eine Leberzrose hin.
Als Differenzialdiagnosen kommen, ich habe nicht gehört,
Virale hepatit, Magenkarsenum oder Reisdarm-Sendro.
Ich habe die Anonyse in Betra.
Zur Abklarung der Beschwerden sollten die folgenden Maslamen durchgeführt werden.
So erst würde ich den Patienten körperlich untersuchen.
Worauf achten Sie bei der körperlichen Unterrufe?
Bei der Körperlehung untersuchen, achte ich darauf,
ob Hautveränderungen, wie Telejktasi, Spidernöwe und Icterus,
wo achten Sie?
Ich beobachte auch, ich palpiere alle Bauche.
Den ganzen Bauch?
Ja, den ganzen Bauch.
Ich beobachte auf Loslassschmerz,
Abklarspannung oder Druckschmerz.
Ich würde auskultieren die Baunen und Lunge und Herz.
Ich würde auskultieren.
Ich würde die Blut abnehmen und einige Labelwerte überprüfen.
Was ist das für eine andere?
Ich würde große Blutbilder, Entsündung, Parameter, Lebe- und Nierenwerte, Elektro- und Obst.
Ich würde die Diagnose auskultieren.
Ich würde die Epatite-Marken auskultieren.
Ich würde die Albumin-Blu-Rubin-5-Lasse machen.
Ich würde die Sonografie des Abdomens durchkultieren.
Was erwarten Sie?
Der Patient hat Acetes.
Ich würde die Acetes bestätigen.
Ich würde die andere Epatologie auslesen.
Ich würde die Diagnose bestätigen.
Noch einen wichtigen Punkt.
Haben Sie aber bestimmt schon gedacht?
Ja, ich erfälle den Patienten Alkohol und Nukutinka.
Wozu müssen wir achten, wenn wir nicht dazu mehr haben?
Wenn er kein Alkohol bekommt?
Was besteht da für eine Gefahr?
Wenn der Patient Alkohol hat,
wenn wir Alkohol reduzieren,
dann ist es eine Zementome.
Da müssen wir mit Rechnung, dass der Instellier kommt
und müssen ihn entsprechend abfangen.
Wir können Alkohol langsam reduzieren.
Ich bin gespannt, was bei Ihren Untersuchungen rauskommt.
Halten Sie mich bitte auf dem Laufenden über die Ergebnisse.
Insbesondere die Leberwerte,
was es in der Labor sagt.
Ich bin auch gespannt, wie der Sonografie befunden ist.
Dann sehen wir uns nachher beim Patienten am Bett.
Danke schön.
Ja, das war noch schön.
Ich habe ganz wenig, wo ich etwas zu sagen kann.
Wie ist der Zahnproblem?
Er wiegt 86 kg.
Er hat gesagt, er braucht ein paar Päckchen Zigaretten am Tag.
Sie haben daraus nur eine gemacht.
Sie haben nicht näher nachgefragt.
Er ist ein Kettenraucher.
Er hat gesagt, er sei vollständig geimpft.
Er hat gesagt, er hat eine Covid-Impfung gemacht.
Er ist ein bisschen schluffig.
Er hat keine vollständige Impfung.
Er hat keine vollständige Covid-Impfung.
Man muss vermuten, dass der Rest nicht funktioniert.
Was er gesagt hat,
haben Sie gesagt,
dass er sich anstrengt,
dass er keine Luft bekommt.
Er hat beschrieben,
Er hat beschrieben.
Alles andere war komplett.
Auch ihr Vorgehen hinterher,
was Sie beschrieben haben.
Die Differenzialdiagnosen, die diagnostischen Maßnahmen,
die therapeutischen Maßnahmen,
das war alles völlig abgreien.
Sie haben das auch sprachlich schön gemacht.
Es ist immer noch ein bisschen dazwischen.
Aber das kriegt man auch ganz schwer raus.
Ich weiß nicht, wie viele hundertmal ich im Laufe eines Abends
oder eines Gesprächs selber auch äh machen.
Aber es ist schon ein bisschen häufig bei Ihnen,
versuchen Sie noch mal ein bisschen im Alltag daran zu arbeiten
oder sich vielleicht so schlüssige Formulierungen zu machen.
Es ist auffällig, wenn Sie nach Plan sprechen können.
Wenn Sie nach Plan sprechen können, haben Sie das ganz wenig.
Aber wenn eine Zwischenfrage kommt,
dann haut Sie so ein bisschen aus dem Konzept.
Wenn Sie freie Formulieren müssen,
dann schleicht sich das wieder verstärkt ein.
Natürlich ist es im Arztgespräch mehr,
als im Anamnesegespräch.
Da sind Sie ja derjenige, der führt, der die Richtung vorgibt.
Sie haben es schöne Formulierungen geführt, ist Ihnen aufgefallen.
Sie haben bemerkt, ja, sehr schön.
Da sind Sie der Gesprächsführer
und haben das Heft gut in der Hand.
Da machen Sie auch nicht so viel äh dazwischen.
Aber wenn Sie selber derjenige sind, der freie Formulierend berichten soll,
haben Sie es natürlich viel schwerer.
Es nimmt Ihnen auch keiner übel.
Ich denke mal, Sie können getrost und fröhlich in Ihre Prüfung gehen.
Im September ist sie doch erst, oder?
Nein, nächste Woche.
Aber ich denke mal, das sitzen Sie getrost aus
und da Wochenende,
da brauchen Sie sich keine Sorgen zu machen.
Ja, sehr hart.
Okay.
Wir können diese Alkoholkonsum,
5-Rib-Übermäßige Alkoholkonsum, oder?
Kann man schon Alkoholabusus bezeichnen.
Ja, also besteht Alkoholabusus von 5-6 Flaschen Bier am Tag
zusätzlich mehrere Gläserschnaps.
Das hat er ja gar nicht so genau gesagt.
Das kann man schon als Alkoholabusus bezeichnen.